[Music]
mm breasts but it's verified and welcome
to the curse of the chocolate fountain
it's probably what is holy [ __ ] I can't
stop make holy Wow
I mean I can't stop making boobs this
would be a magical experience if not for
the books this is true I think it I am
provides his magical experience oh no
Doc's really really there's a lot of
[ __ ] games these days but this one is
one not to run a good the whole
situation is foul I would have degree me
I'm pretty good at this game first time
I play it I'm brought five I guess I'm
just natural born dr. Dodger what the
[ __ ] is that
get away from me now oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] get
it
holy wow what is this orange bird thing
I love her your voice saying holy [ __ ]
greetings greatest virgin what how am I
supposed to read oh my gosh a bird what
a hat with a hat what kind of bird are
you an awesome bird I am what American
Indians called spirit oh wow I once saw
the Indians were just full of [ __ ] get
it well fine
I saw them flying by from a great
distance truly I've never seen a bird
fly swiftly us now I'll stop it dude
thanks it's the boom boom it would be a
dollar if I could fly alongside that
well go ahead I feel like you would any
way feel free bro I can use some company
then let us be partners
for the duration about your Janice and
so the epic genican begins watch out
behind myself oh god damn it
sorry geez I didn't mean to shell on you
just don't fly behind me damn it
[ __ ] keep or were some ducks
ah why am i naked I mean why not yes
okay I keep flying no you you did not do
dive you babe son of a donkey a guy must
have [ __ ] eaten gazillion tacos or
something oh thank the gods the bridge
seemed to have passed as Giz looks
[ __ ] then I can just farm into a
blood destiny I might oh cool beings
like I thought it would be dope attack
right now this game just makes too much
sense for me right now I owe you [ __ ]
Dutch nah why this is what I call
quality gameplay [ __ ] and killing
dogs oh man I'm so happy right now
this cave is beautiful this game is
alright okay okay I'm getting that I'm
chopping up their head or Doug okay my
biceps Quinta you Shirley's Simone judo
spreads thanks Gary
oh hey Stella can't stop [ __ ] good
whether he's named Jerry anyway yes I
had not failed to notice you are truly a
passionate man I think that's what it's
that good I know
on come on
why why ducks I thought you were on my
side doc what did I ever do to you
except killing all your family
the geese I can understand because I
don't like you you are so skilled at
smiting birds it's a little disturbing
I'm more disturbed by the fact that I'm
good me too actually it must have been
expelled ten times my body weight by now
I think a lot more it seems impossible
from us physiological perspective I'm
beginning to question my faith faith
after you good and what kind of universe
could one man poop sir and is that a
universe in which one to exit just ex
existentialism by the gods Icarus oh
[ __ ] Nazis you
Oh goddamnit not is making me naked
again
I stood - boom boom is taka dead yeah
he's reloading attack the tail well
that's [ __ ] anyway but slow day on and
off you know it I dab that bit cute
yeah miss madam you I really don't want
to redo this [ __ ] got it [ __ ] no you
know it's okay
oh god no just no just no I don't you
Oh gameplay Xbox 360 nein nein nein nein
nein Josh ich bin der boom I am the
ultimate boom boom die and we have been
vanquished yes well done
I don't think those guys spoke a word of
good good 12 hours
yeah I'm really curious how the [ __ ]
this started okay just minding my own
business I see a car is fried bottom
resident oh hey what's up bill what a
five dollar Chinese book oh this is this
explains everything
Jenna this game is really realistic if
you think about it
I'm so [ __ ] there I'm going to eat so
much Chinese food that God will cry I'm
driving to your house as fast as I
[ __ ] can and then we're going to the
[ __ ] Chinese buffet if only you knew
our diet just and mortar what do we do
now I love this game I'm so surprised I
thought I thought you know the dark part
was it Oh
dragons of court what the [ __ ] are you
holy Moses who the heck are you my name
just snatch my turn please tell me about
yourself
well I make a rice fried button and this
is my spread animal Jerry so I can't
stop making boo-boo
it seems you are pitting in my face an
alligator that is
boo boo when I began to peepee at first
I was fearful but it gave me power I'm
like a god a ping ping I could rule the
skies I could rule the galaxy like I let
his dick is that there is only room with
these guys for whatever Icarus I would
appreciate him and stop hitting on me oh
it's going down
oh [ __ ] Nelly oh [ __ ] but activate power
activate power I'll [ __ ] on you sir yay
we'll meet again a caress and when we do
we will [ __ ] and pee on each other
you're in big trouble I was truly a
terrible track so I couldn't help but
notice that his spirit animal gave him
goddamn fire balls and not a shitty
night oh I don't think you have the
right you're the man Lily can't stop
[ __ ] I was just kidding Jay you're a
good friend
be cool yes we cool we cool any Twyla
Harry I love this [ __ ] I'm so surprised
oh boy I'm gonna eat so much Chinese
food egg rolls general TS okay I'm
literally going to stop my body cavity
with China me yes surely nothing wrong
go wrong today lettuce
this game just makes more and more sense
the more you playing oh [ __ ] welcome wow
I never knew I lived so close to New
York City
well me neither look the sizes of the
statues never sick buildings now fliter
neighbors unleash the military god
damage anything but the military touch
oh god no not my touch
well all this they don't look anything
do the credit maybe old ducks are
military dog who knows I'm so lame oh I
fight in this adventures doc we only had
the month of July to craft our defenses
there's nothing cooler I can fight
wait it's President Barack Obama oh my
god is present Barack Obama holy [ __ ]
yes Icarus it's me I'm gonna end this
episode here but I hope you've enjoyed
watching leave a like for ducks
I'll see you in the next one Samus love
you the Carlton Oh
[Music]